bitcoin has seen immense traction and
adoption globally over the last few
years everyone seems to be trying to
plug into the bitcoin network and most
recently in the media bitcoin has been
talked about being censorship resistant
which is what we saw happening in canada
to being sanction resistant which is
what we saw happening with russia and
ukraine today everyone seems to be
trying to plug into this almost one
trillion dollar asset from governments
and nation states to cities and citizens
everyone's trying to utilize bitcoin and
the bitcoin payment network to be able
to make the lives of their citizens
easier and better but also grow their
economy or their personal investment
portfolio as a whole now the latest city
to do this and the last domino to fall
on the chain was luganu lugano is the
ninth largest city in switzerland with a
population of around 64 000 people and
they have now made bitcoin legal tender
let me say that again luganu has now
made bitcoin legal tender the ninth
largest city in switzerland has now made
bitcoin legal tender what does this mean
this means that citizens have the
ability to pay for taxes and other
services in bitcoin while also
transacting with over 200 local
businesses and paying for goods and
services from them as well in bitcoin
now legano is not the first city or
first nation state to plug into the
bitcoin network most recently in
september of last year we saw el
salvador make bitcoin legal tender they
went ahead and now have immense growth
in their book chiva wallet out more
people have the chivo wallet out than
have traditional bank accounts but
they've also seen over double-digit
growth in their gdp for the first time
in history that's right for the first
time in history they have seen over a 10
growth in their gdp by plugging into the
bitcoin network they also saw a 30
increase in tourism and everything else
that comes along with plugging into the
bitcoin network they have garnered
attention globally and now we're seeing
another city gluganu plug into the
bitcoin network it will be interesting
to see how these citizens and how this
government utilizes bitcoin and how they
truly plug into the bitcoin network but
this is an exciting time for bitcoin and
i cannot wait to see what lugano can do
for its citizens and the government of
switzerland as a whole hey you did you
like this video great we make five of
them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time